so you're shooting the final season of
Game of Thrones yes top top top secret
yes no cellphones no nothing I'm gonna
try to make a little bit of news a tiny
bit of news what was your reaction to
Daenerys final scene yeah it's really oh
my goodness it really is the most
heartbreaking thing to be filming the
last of everything so I get really I've
become an emotional wreck on set
regardless they're like I mean oh it's
an inside of your hand it's okay and I'm
like then they just get over it now like
we need to get somewhere done so I'm yes
overall anything to anything be it an
emotional scene or not is just kind of
making me very sad what are you gonna
remember most from being on this show
your everything the people that just we
have like the best crew in the world
ever with us yeah hey everybody its
Charlie so Emilia Clarke is out
promoting her brand-new movie she's
talking a lot about Game of Thrones in
the final season she did another big
interview where she revealed that she
has completely finished filming on
season 8 that's right
not including pickups or anything that
they might add at the last minute to
bring her back in for or looping her
dialogue she also revealed that she has
a lot of scenes with main characters
that she's never had scenes with before
some of them you can probably guess
right off the top of your head she
quoted Sansa and Arya Stark but then you
also have people like Jaime Lannister
who I'm actually more excited to see her
have scenes with the person who killed
her father and was last seen trying to
kill her running her down with that
spear so let's break it down if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
heading into the summer they're getting
ready to finish filming all of season 8
they'll be coming to Comic Cons so I'll
remind everyone about what's going on
with that that's happening at the end of
July if you've been following the
production you've probably heard people
talking about them filming additional
scenes at the dragon pit it makes sense
that they would go back there it's such
an important place in the history of
King's Landing in the history of the
Targaryen family so if he Turner also
implied that they're finished filming
most of what they're going to be doing
up in the North around Winterfell that
doesn't mean that everybody's done
filming up at Winterfell it just means
the sophie Turner and a lot of the
actors are probably done Clark talked a
little bit about Daenerys Sansa in aria
meeting each other and what their
relationship is gonna be like you can
imagine sunset Aria are very different
types of personalities so they're gonna
have very different reactions to
Daenerys Sansa being the self ascribed
politician spent most of the last couple
of seasons trying to retake Winterfell
in the name of her family she's the most
traditional of the surviving stark
family and even though she's not as
pissed off about the idea of Daenerys
Targaryen retaking the Iron Throne is
everybody else if you remember back to
the beginning of season seven she was
also very much against Jon Snow leaving
Winterfell to go work or try to work
with Daenerys then send an emissary
don't go yourself Daenerys is a queen
only a king can convince her to help us
it has to be me you're abandoning your
people you're abandoning your home all
of the lords and ladies if you're
talking about Sansa of the north do not
like the idea of Daenerys Yan Royce was
just the most vocal a bit like he was
the one that was standing up shouting at
Jon Snow when he started to raise the
idea of Daenerys your grace with respect
I must agree with Lady Sansa
I remember the Mad King all too well a
Targaryen cannot be trusted
but it does seem like most of the early
drama between those characters is going
to be all about Sansa trying to
reconcile the idea of Daenerys Targaryen
now that doesn't say anything about the
bomb that bran and Sam will are probably
going to drop on them oh by the way
you're a secret Targaryen this person
that you trotted in here is your new
girlfriend is actually your aunt you'll
be getting it on with your aunt this
whole time then that's probably where
most of the drama will shift to
complicating the Starks feelings about
Daenerys but I think the brand bomb is
mostly going to cause drama between John
and Daenerys most of the Lords of the
north already hate Daenerys brands BOM
isn't going to change that if they
already hated her they're probably still
going to hate her there are only a
couple of people that I'm expecting to
react favorably to Daenerys in Arya is
one of them now I wouldn't say really
favorably she mostly loves John she's
like the leader of the Jon Snow fan club
when she finds out that he's Aegon
Targaryen she's probably not gonna treat
him too differently maybe crack a couple
Joe
all that history that drama won't matter
to her she'll still feel like he's her
brother and we'll treat him the same way
but because the whole thing with aria is
that she's supposed to have the skills
of a faceless person the stone-cold
killer I wouldn't be surprised if they
try to have some fun with the idea that
she talked to Daenerys and says if you
hurt my brother I will stab you so fast
like some moment that acknowledges that
she is a deadly killer in that even
though she might not hate Daenerys she
won't hesitate to kill her the only
people that I'm expected to be really
excited about Daenerys will be torment
in the wildlings like tormund's reaction
to Brienne like he was fascinated by her
because he'd never seen a woman like
this I would expect him to have a
similar reaction to the Dragons just
completely fascinated and terrified at
the same time like oh my god I've never
seen anything like this before but like
I said the actor that I'm most looking
forward to Daenerys having scenes with
she's never had scenes with before is
Jaime Lannister so he's a little more
sensible it seems like Daenerys
understands a little bit about what her
father was but she still has that
Targaryen temper they showed a little
bit during season seven but I think that
Jon Snow helped her mellow out just a
little bit but it's that wonderful
tension of them acknowledging the fact
that Jaime Lannister was dubbed the
Kingslayer for killing her father
effectively ending Robert's rebellion so
she'll probably acknowledge that like I
hate you but I understand what you did
and I know that you had to do it and
speaking of the end of Robert's
rebellion now that we can actually
pinpoint the date of Jon Snow's birth
much more accurately we actually know
Jon Snow himself is just a little bit
older than Daenerys so think about it
this way the Mad King was killed in 283
marking the end of Robert's rebellion or
the main thrust of Robert's rebellion
John was born very shortly after that
during the same year and then supposedly
Daenerys was conceived in the final
month of Robert's rebellion the Mad King
sent his wife to Dragonstone to give
birth so Daenerys was born on
Dragonstone during a big storm that's
why they call her Daenerys Stormborn
remember season 7 episode 2 was
literally titled Stormborn and it was
like the first full episode with her
being at Dragonstone if she was
conceived during the final month of
Robert's rebellion and was born nine
months later you have to imagine that
even though she's not a full calendar
year younger than Johnson oh she was
born during 284 John was born during 283
so technically he is the older of the
two so which is another reason why he
has a more legitimate claim to the
throne when you think about it though
Samwell and bran are the only two that
have put all that information together
so unless Samwell can start producing
documents I don't think it's gonna be
that big of an issue I think it's gonna
be all about the drama of Daenerys
trying to realize that there is a more
legitimate candidate than her and she's
been all about retaking the Iron Throne
so how is she going to deal with the
idea that Sheena has to share that with
John Snow even though she cares about
him she felt like she was the one that
was destined to do all these things but
let it be known if you do get into any
arguments with your friends about who
has the stronger claim to the throne
remember male favouring primogenitor
meaning that the line of succession used
to pass to the oldest living male heir
so it would pass to Rhaegar after the
Mad King died if Rhaegar was dead it
would pass to his oldest living male
heir who is Jon Snow a lot of people
were asking george RR martin about this
issue when Cersei seized the throne
during season six because technically if
you're talking about male favouring
primogenitor he would pass through the
oldest living male Baratheon cousin no
matter which family he currently
belonged to before it would pass to
Cersei right now Gendry is Robert's
oldest living male heir so if he were
legitimized the line of succession would
pass to him if you're gonna keep it in
the Baratheon family but obviously that
hasn't happened yet
so technically he's an option B when
you're talking about your main
candidates for taking the Iron Throne
but you can actually see how the Lords
of the north would probably favor a
Baratheon successor over our Targaryen
successor but remember there's only six
episodes don't expect them to get into
too much politicking
this is probably going to be a B and C
plot during the season the a plot being
fighting the night king but let me know
in the comments how much drama
do you think there's going to be about
who should be the technical successor to
the Iron Throne when they find out who
Gendry is and when they find out who
John is that he's really a gaunt argh
in the Gendry is really a Baratheon
there's a new round of the DVD giveaway
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video uh name a new winner when I post
new Game of Thrones
there will be more Game of Thrones
dropping when we get to the summer in
Comic Con so if you're bummed out that
there isn't a whole lot of Game of
Thrones being talked about right now
that will change later this year I am
expecting Comic Con footage of some kind
click here for more Season eight videos
and click here for my new Westworld
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight